In Mexico, Mexican police and soldiers have arrested a suspect...
...involved in the disappearance of three Italian men.
In Indonesia, President Joko Widodo visited Lombok Island...
...on Monday and promised financial aid...
...to people who lost their homes in Sunday's powerful earthquake...
...that killed 16 and injured 162.
In Cambodia, the opposition calls on the international community...
...to reject the results of Sunday's election that ended with a victory...
...for the ruling party and long-serving Prime Minister Hun Sen.
In Tajikistan, four tourists from the United States,...
...Switzerland and the Netherlands were killed Sunday...
...in what may have been a terrorist act, authorities say.
Finally, a heat wave of up to 38 degrees Celsius sweeps across northern Italy.
Zoo animals and people stay cool by having ice treats...
...and washing in the fountains.